Salut ! Aujourd'hui je suis avec Lorène, alias Girlita.
-Salut !
De la chaine Girlita.
Lorène, sur sa chaine elle fait du DIY. C'est du Do It Yourself.
-On fait nous même, plein d'objets. Ça peut-être des bijoux, de la décoration, des petits trucs utiles de tous les jours.
Je ne suis pas un bon bricoleur, c'est comme ça ! Faut que je l'assume !
Je ne peux pas avoir toutes les qualités, déjà que je chante extrêmement bien !
Aujourd'hui Lorène est venue à la maison, et on a fabriqué ensemble, un jeu.
Ce jeu là.
C'est le jeu des bâtonnets comme dans Fort Boyard.
Je pense que c'est un dérivé du jeu de Nim, mais là c'est le jeu des bâtonnets version Lorène et Fabien,
Autant vous dire... il y a du level.
On va jouer à ça, je te propose que l'on fasse trois parties et moi je vais écrire une petite prédiction ici.
-Ok.
Mon but n'est pas de gagner ou de perdre. Mon but est surtout que la prédiction se réalise.
Voilà, avec ma belle écriture je vais vous faire voir. Par contre, Lorène il ne faut pas que tu regardes parce qu'il y a l'écran de retour.
Vous vous avez la prédiction dès le départ.
[lancement de dé]
Tu as fait 5 !
Moi je vais peut-être faire 7...
[rires]
[lancement de dé]
J'ai fait 4 !
Ok, donc c'est toi qui commence !
Ah oui... la règle du jeu c'est quoi déjà ?
hum...
-On a le droit d'enlever 1,2 ou 3 bâtonnets et le but c'est de ne pas prendre le dernier.
Ok, on peut en prendre 1,2 ou 3 et nous devons pas prendre le dernier. D'accord.
Alors moi j'en enlève un.
Je mettrai surement ce passage là en accéléré. Je vous le dis, je vais accélérer ce passage.
Ah mais le but c'est de ne pas prendre le dernier, c'est ça ?!
-Oui.
[rires]
Et bien je perds cette première partie, dignement et avec élégance, et la prochaine fois j'écouterai les consignes !
Donc tu gagnes la première.
On joue encore avec le dé ? Celui qui a le plus grand nombre commence ?
-Oui.
[lancement de dés]
2 !
-Moi 5.
D'accord, alors c'est toujours toi qui commence de toute manière, j'ai bien compris...
J'ai envie d'en prendre 3 !
[rires]
-Ca m'aurai étonné.
J'ai envie que l'on soit ex aequo. Et je gagne cette nouvelle partie.
On fait une dernière partie.
[lancement des dés]
5 !
-4 !
Bien joué. Allez j'en prends trois.
Je prends les trois. Et je te laisse prendre le dernier pour perdre dignement.
T'as gagné la première mais tu as perdu les deux autres.
Et d'ailleurs j'avais une petite prédiction avec moi. La prédiction que je leur avais fait voir tout à l'heure
c'est le tableau des scores:
Je perds la première, tu gagnes la première, et ensuite je gagne les deux autres et toi tu perds les deux autres.
-Donc là tu m'as laissé gagner ?
En effet, à la première je t'ai laissé gagner.
-Mais tu te souvenais des règles ?
Oui, je me souvenais des règles.
[rires]
Ah c'est pour ça que tu fais cette tête la depuis tout à l'heure devant la prédiction.
"Alala j'ai oublié les règles, je ne m'en souviens plus..."
C'était crédible ?
-Ouais, ça va.
Elle se dit "ouais c'est ça ouais !"
Pour ça j'ai utilisé une méthode qui me permet de gagner à tous les coups à ce jeu, quoi qu'il arrive.
Que ce soit toi qui commence ou moi qui commence, je sais exactement comme faire depuis le départ pour gagner.
Et cette explication, je vais vous la donner.
C'est plutôt cool !
Mais je ne vais pas vous la donner ici, je vais vous la donner directement sur la chaine de Lorène.
Je vais vous mettre une fiche juste ici, qui renvoie vers la chaine de Lorène, mais surtout vers la vidéo
où on vous explique tous les deux, parce que oui j'explique avec Lorène,
comment on a fabriqué ce jeu, comment vous pouvez vous le fabriquer.
Et surtout à la fin de la vidéo je vous donne l'astuce pour pouvoir gagner à tous les coups à ce jeu là.
Et devenir le roi de Fort Boyard.
Il y a une vraie méthode même pour une infinité de bâtons.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé la vidéo. Je vous donne rendez-vous dans quelques secondes sur la chaine de Lorène.
Profitez-en pour vous abonner à sa chaine parce que c'est vraiment cool.
Si ça vous a plu, n'hésitez à nous le faire savoir en nous laissant un petit...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
Pensez également à vous abonner à la chaine et rendez-vous demain à 11H pour un prochain Mental Vlog.
Parce que c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Ciao !